Tracy Lee being the acting returning
officer for the election of the Member
of Parliament for Plymouth more view
constituency held on the 8th of June
2017 do hereby declare that the number
of votes cast for each candidate is as
follows Sudan Labour Party 18,000 548
Johnny Mercer the Conservative Party
candidate 23,000 567 Wendy Noble UK
Independence Party you KITT 1849 Joshua
George Pope the Green Party 536
Grahame Richard Reid Liberal Democrat
917 the number of ballot papers rejected
was 17 I therefore declare that Johnny
Mercer is duly elected as the Member of
Parliament for the Plymouth more view
constituency
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much I'd like
to thank all the staff who've done such
a brilliant job in putting on this
election I know that since Tuesday
you've been working all the hours to
work through the various snags that
we've had and thank you for your efforts
on that I'd like to thank my team no one
ever achieved anything significant on
their own and my team have been
phenomenal if you look at what we built
up from nothing been my agent has been
extraordinary and of course there's my
wife who continues to get dragged rounds
pretty sure people think they're voting
for her
rather than me but there we go I'd like
to pay tribute Oliver Coble as well
you're not going to get any of that
nastiness for me I think that he has
done in seven years he has worked hard
for this city and in 25 years
Gary Street has done the same Plymouth
is on a journey and I look forward to I
look forward to taking it away I mean
nationally this result tonight it
shatters the way politics has run for a
long time in this country it's a timely
reminder who drives this particular
train of democracy and the people and I
think it's I think it's a good thing the
sands of time of shifting politics and
with it a new generation of politicians
I think it's exciting and somebody who
got into politics because basically he
was fed up with how everyone else was
doing it I think it's great I think
we're full of opportunities undetermined
to seize them for a modern compassionate
conservative party with Plymouth at the
center of that thank you very much
[Applause]